you look great thanks for coming thank
you for having me um you know what i was
thinking about this today you're you're
20 years old yeah i'm correct
but that 70s show has been on for how
many years did i say six
six had its seventh year so you got that
job when you were 14 years
old how did you do that i mean is that
even legal
it's illegal well it's not illegal it's
just that they wanted somebody who's 18
or older
right or emancipated right so i lied um
the story has been said before it was
one of those things where i went in and
said i was going to be 18
right they didn't ask when so it's okay
that's like two years later i was gonna
be 18.
right you could have also said i'm going
to be 80.
if i take good care of myself right
absolutely wow yeah that's right but
then when i signed the contract i was
like um i need a studio teacher and
they're like what why and i'm like oh
cause i'm 14.
wow and it was too late then it was too
late and then you say suckers
exactly then i fooled them did you um do
you have big plans for your 21st
birthday because for a lot of people
that's a like they have like a big cool
plan for that you know i
kind of do i don't really drink and i
don't really do anything so for my 21st
birthday i really want to do everything
so i want to go to vegas and just
completely go bonkers for one night
oh my god so the words out that you want
to go to vegas on your 21st birthday and
when you say do everything well i'm
gonna be with my parents so now do
everything everything okay
i'm still gonna be you know so if you're
bringing your parents you're not gonna
be doing anything you're like
i bring my parents but i'm still gonna
do everything rock and
it's not like roll you eating captain
crunch watching tv
yeah wait are you gonna have a little
drinky poo or something
a little bit yeah okay i like to call it
drinky poop uh i understand that in your
home you have a piece of art that's
actually from our
show okay so here's the thing i like i
don't like your tone at all right now
i don't like any story thinking okay
yeah here's the thing
you better change this whole attitude
right now
okay i really liked your show until
one day i was watching the show with my
boyfriend and you know he does those
segments with like if they made it
right right our baby came out so ugly
well that's sort of the idea behind if
they made it
can i ask them to look and let them
decide is that okay
go ahead we showed a picture of you and
your your significant other macaulay
culkin
and we showed a picture and we decided
and we decided to uh show what would
happen if you two ever had a child what
would it look like let's take a look and
see i'm just curious
that's a good looking kid
andy i think you should decide isn't
that a good looking child i think that
if they really do make the hobbit
your kids
that kid's gonna work yeah that kid's
gonna get a lot of work
that's what we're trying to say yeah now
let me ask you uh
uh i i understand that although you were
jewish you like to celebrate christmas
is that true
yeah i like presents so i'll celebrate
anything
i'll celebrate kwanzaa all right
everybody gives me a present right so i
have a tree in my house a christmas tree
that i bought at kmart it rotates
and it rotates what do you mean it i
like it plug it in right
and it rotates okay that explains
everything
i realize i'm the idiot it rotates
what's happening
it's in a stand right it's pre-lit and
it rotates
what just goes in the circle and you
just put it up at christmas no it's all
year round
oh so you have a christmas theme in your
apartment
yeah cause well it started off because i
was too lazy to take it down because it
comes in three pieces and i was like ah
screw it i'm just gonna leave it up and
then it just became like a theme of my
house like i have my christmas lights up
i have like the fake snow on my table
it's really disturbing
it's like july and i'm like go christmas
but i still celebrate hanukkah
right you still celebrate hanukkah but
you know what i've noticed is that i
think peop there that
jewish people because i've met a bunch
of jewish people who have said that they
also celebrate christmas
and i think they do it because it's kind
of easy to figure out you get the tree
and
that's easy to figure out words i don't
know as many uh like christian people
that celebrate
like i myself i don't understand uh
hanukkah i don't there's a dreidel and
there's some cookies and there's a
there's this i don't understand it
either right i'm like a really bad jew i
never
really i like i said i celebrated so
many rabbis are angrily watching right
now
i celebrate christmas i'm a bad jew i
don't know i want the presents i i
understand
that no i mean hanukkah is a beautiful
holiday but good save
it's a wonderful time of career is still
alive yeah
well no my parents are watching going oh
my god yeah um well don't worry you can
make it up to them on that big 21st
blowout in vegas sorry about the whole
putting down the jewish holiday thing
yeah i guess let's pate and do jello
shots
i understand you're very unhappy about
the uh the the bug
man coming up yeah why wasn't i tomorrow
with bra
nothing against you
rather than me too that makes no
sense i know you wish you could leave
your own body and become bradford yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i'm so scared of bugs like you don't
understand i don't think anybody in this
world exists that's more
i love birds because they eat bugs i
don't like bugs you only like
birds because they destroy and eat bugs
wow i'm so you love the natural enemy of
the bug
look at nothing against people who love
bugs i'm all for it like good save
you're saving things left and right
saving things bug people
yep um so bug loving rabbis now love you
again
that's the important thing yeah well uh
you'll be protected i think i'm going to
be over in that area there
with uh what i'm told are some deadly
bugs right and you'll be protected over
here
if they come anywhere near me i will
freak i might pee my pants i don't like
bugs
where i'm from that's good
[Laughter]
the 150th episode of that 70's show airs
sunday may 16th at 8 30 pm on fox and
mia's new movie tony and tina's wedding
is now playing
at the tribeca film festival in new york
city
thanks for coming on thank you yeah
really nice to have you here mila kunis
we'll be right back
with the bug guy george broussard
you